[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans cette nouvelle
édition spéciale nous sommes le lundi 20
avril
on fait le point tout de suite sur la
propagation du pot vie 19 dans les
yvelines selon les données de santé
publique france au 19 avril
334 personnes sont décédées dans les
hôpitaux depuis le début de la pandémie
un chiffre qui reste stable depuis deux
jours par ailleurs 894 personnes étaient
hospitalisées 1113 patients ont par
ailleurs pu retourner à leur domicile
c'est le 35ème jours de confinement et
parmi les professionnels qui n'ont
jamais cessé est d'exercer depuis le
début de la crise sanitaire les sages
femmes
leur rôle est essentiel pour accompagner
les femmes enceintes et répondre à leurs
interrogations sur leur futur
accouchement en fils points avec
mathilde de 2 min bonsoir un de ses
goûts des taux vous êtes sages femmes à
bois d'arcy exerçant à saint quentin en
yvelines
alors comment avez vous adaptez votre
activité face au confinement
alors la culture est elle même parce que
en fait on a annulé toutes les
consultations urgentes type rééducation
du périnée suivi gynécologique nous
nuire gens voilà tout ça a été annulé
pour purement et simplement
et puis on a maintenu le suivi de
grossesse standard en adaptant c'est à
dire en prenant que certaines
consultations des cinq groupes et dans
les cabinets d'échographie les
échographies de suivi de grossesse et
avec l'examen mensuel et puis nous pour
voir les au concept ma bêtise grossesse
les dames sophie pour l'access il était
de les voir au centre au quatrième au
sixième mois
et puis
cette huitième mois de façon
systématique au moins des choeurs du
bébé en d'attention des choses qu'on
peut pas faire à distance
vous effectuez quand même des
consultations a donné cela fait toujours
des consultations domicile oui les
consultations domicile par lens
ce sont surtout les consultations de
suivi de grossesse pathologique qui
nécessitent par exemple un monitoring et
les consultations de retour à domicile
après accouchement avec le co villa dans
les maternités comme les papas ne
peuvent pas rester comme en séjour en
maternité ne pas venir lui peut pas y
avoir de visite un peu plus de sorties
précoces
c'est à dire choix soit avant 72 heures
après l'accouchement d'un bras ce soit
avant 96 heures après un accouchement
par césarienne
il ya un peu plus de sorties précoces de
maternité qui nécessitent des visites à
domicile dès lendemain de la sortie on a
vu en france qu'il y avait beaucoup de
femmes c'est à coucher sans leur
partenaire
est-ce que c'est aussi le cas dans les
yvelines alors sans leur partenaire non
très peu parce que c'est sûr qu'il ya eu
au départ c'est un peu tâtonné parce
qu'il ya des maternités qui ont des
vannes où on parle pas passer trop ceci
dit être cela puis maintenant et quand
même un consensus qui dit que le matin
est présent s'il présente pas de filles
du coc u19 il va être présente pendant
l'accouchement est juste soit 2 3 heures
après l'accouchement
au moins c'est déjà ça et après il a
rentré chez lui et la maman nous à
rester à la maternité sans avoir de
visite
et qu'est ce que vous pourriez dire un
couple qui se prêtent pas prochainement
accueillir un nouveau né et s'il ya des
mesures à prendre à la maison peut-être
je voulais dire vis-à-vis du comité 19
mai jour de fonction non il n'y a pas de
mesure particulière à prendre d'autres
que les mesures barrières simple
évidemment bien se laver les mains
éviter de postillonner sur le bébé va
éviter de faire trop de bisous c'est
terrible
mais même pour un bébé ses priorités la
lutte - très protecteur c'est à dire
qu'une femme qui veut à l'été a tout
intérêt à faire même si elle est
porteuse du corps et commis de 10,9 en
respectant les mesures barrières c'est à
dire en portant le masque en se lavant
les mains et et en allaitant surtout
continuez à cet égard pas de
transmissions du candidat par le nez et
même le lait maternel est très
protecteur vis-à-vis des maladies toutes
les maladies c'est un élément essentiel
de prévention
donc voilà et est-ce que depuis la
période du confinement vous recevez
beaucoup d'appels de femmes inquiètes
je reçois plus de 2,2 monde pour savoir
si mentir la préparation à la naissance
la préparation à la naissance doit être
continu continu et doit être doit à toi
ô combien la préparation à la naissance
et on va le faire plus tôt en télé
consultation dans ces cas là puisqu'on a
la chance d'avoir pu adapter leurs
pratiques avec la téléconsultation qui
est prise en charge depuis le 26 mars
donc ça c'est un vraiment un atout
énorme et on peut le faire de la
préparation la naissance
téléconsultation donc on a des gens
inquiets vis-à-vis du comité neuf et
surtout vis-à-vis du fait il aurait pu
ne pas pouvoir se préparer donc on doit
pouvoir rassurer les parents on peut le
faire au moment de la préparation à
distance répondra aux questions à
distance rend téléconsultation en
visioconférence comme on a les moyens et
s'est pris en charge par la sécurité
sociale depuis 26 mars
merci à me theiss légaux les taux de
nous avoir répondu avec des yeux un
chiffre à présent à 17 milles c'est le
nombre d'entreprises yvelinoise qui ont
demandé le chômage partiel et gérard
bacheliers et président de la chambre de
commerce et d'industrie des yvelines il
nous en dit plus sur la situation
économique dans notre département il est
interrogé par nicolas landry
nous avons dix sept mille établissements
donc qui en demandait le chômage partiel
qui représente à peu près de 112 1722
salariés c'est à peu près 50 % des
établissements de du des yvelines
donc c'est quand même à un point
important avec bien sûr restauration
hôtellerie qui sont les plus marquées et
après bien sûr la l'industrie la
métallerie la construction
c'est une plateforme qui s'appelle cci
entraide qui permet justement des
échanges de solidarité et de
complémentarité entre entreprises donc
les entreprises peuvent faire des offres
où certains recherchent des produits
donc ça permet justement d'avoir des
échanges solidaires entre entreprises
dans cette situation difficile mais ça
peut je pense perdurer par la suite et
je l'espère il ya aussi donc une autre
façon quand on a mis en place ce qui
s'appelle les commerces à domicile qui
permet justement de référence et les
commerces qui ont mis en place des
livraisons à domicile et donc cette
ville dans les yvelines
donc on choisit ce système c'est poissy
mantes la jolie les mureaux maurepas
houdan conflans sainte honorine andré
vie voilà donc c'est une plateforme qui
permet justement d'aider les commerces
de centre-ville dans leur livraison à
domicile
oui cette relance elle va être
progressive à être progressif tout
simplement parce qu'il ya quelques
dirait filière qui vont démarrer comme
le bâtiment et les travaux publics qui
vont démarrer assez vite avant la fin du
mois d'avril
mais bon les difficultés qui vient voir
bien sûr ces deux d'avoir tous les
éléments sanitaires nécessaires pour
justement permettre à ces entreprises de
travailler c'est-à-dire des masques des
blues tout ce qui est nécessaire
et puis une nouvelle organisation du
travail aussi pour les entreprises du
bâtiment et des travaux publics ce qui
va justement créé un surcoût pour ces
entreprises et ce surcoût va se
retrouver bien sûr dans leurs devis et
dans leurs propositions
c'est évident donc c'est un surcoût qui
va être nécessaire
à plus long terme il faut penser à une
relocalisation un autre modèle de
fonctionnement de l'industrie de
l'économie sur nos territoires
il faut profiter justement de ce qui
s'est passé jusqu'à maintenant c'est à
dire de la livraison à domicile des
circuits courts d'une utilisation un peu
plus importante de tout ce qui est de
tout le numérique donc et ça il faut il
faut que ça dure je pense qu'il faut que
ça continue
drive piéton un drive voiture ou encore
livraisons depuis plusieurs jours de
nombreux commerces comme les jardineries
ou manquant les magasins de bricolage
ont repris a partiellement leurs
activités de ventes
ils ont adapté leur rapport aux
consommateurs exemple d'une enseigne
spécialisée dans le multimédia et
l'électroménager elle est installée à
coignières reportage de mathilde et demi
et mélanie poté alors vous allez ouvrir
le coffre de votre véhicule vous mettez
la pièce d'identité à plat dans le
coffre services sans contact parfois
même directement dans le coffre pour
cette cliente le mois de confinement a
rendu nécessaire cet achat l'enseigne
met en avant des produits de nécessité
j'avais un besoin d'imprimantes parce
que mes enfants sont à la maison comme
beaucoup pour mon travail aussi je vais
avoir besoin d'imprimer très bonne idée
ça va parce que je suis tombé en panne
de table a dit hier soir
puma tablettes aujourd'hui c'est parfait
parce qu'il faut maintenir la vie
familiale et notamment les anniversaires
donc il y avait la possibilité d'offrir
un cadeau donc j'en ai profité j'habite
pas très loin depuis le 14 avril
l'enseigne spécialisés installés à
coignières propose un driver piétons
habituellement ouverts 7 jours sur 7
avec 50 collaborateurs
le magasin fonctionne pour le moment
avec six salariés volontaires
la règle est claire la sécurité avant
tout aussi bien pour les clients mais
surtout pour les collaborateurs
donc les clients n'ont pas le droit et
ne rentreront pas en magasin des tables
ont été mises en avant par rapport à ça
l'idée c'est vraiment con qu'on se
protège et encore une fois que le client
aussi soient protégés ce qui est ce qui
est demandé un principalement c'est
vraiment le petit électroménager avec ce
qui se passe on a beaucoup de clients
qui cherchent eux mêmes je pense à faire
leurs pattes leur pain et leur cuisine
donc on commande on a pas mal de robots
justement qui arrivent dans les yvelines
trois autres magasins de la franchise
ont mis en place ce type de drive de
nombreuses enseignes ont adopté ce
système de vente notamment dans le
bricolage et la restauration aide aux
entreprises distribution de masques ou
encore de gel hydro alcoolique depuis le
début de la crise sanitaire la région
ile de france a mis en place de
nombreuses actions afin d'aider les
franciliens et des actions vu également
dû déconfinement annoncé pour le 11 mai
prochain
on fait le point avec alexandra du
blanche elle est vice-présidente de la
région en charge notamment du
développement économique est les propos
sont recueillis par nicolas landry
on a souhaité participer massivement
avec les régions de france au fonds de
solidarité état région qui s'élève
maintenant à 1 milliards 7 et même
l'état annoncée de l'avantagé de mon
temps donc la région y contribue à
hauteur de 30% ce à peu près 80 millions
d'euros que la région mais sur ce fond
pour les très petites entreprises les
commerces les artisans qui ont connu une
baisse de chiffre d'affaires d'au moins
50%
on s'est beaucoup battu pour que ce
chiffre de 50% soit considérée par 70%
comme le départ donc à une première
vague l'assaillait de deux demandes
satisfaites d'ailleurs j'encourage
vraiment les yvelinois continuer à
postuler jusqu'au 30 avril à tête
première vague du fonds de solidarité
parce que l'on pourrait faire un petit
peu mieux je pense vu les difficultés
vous pouvez toucher dans ces cas-là un
chèque qui va jusqu'à 1500 euros
et donc là les régions vont se charger
de la deuxième vague de ce fonds de
solidarité où on peut aller jusqu'à des
montants un peu plus élevée jusqu'à
20000 euros voire 5000 euros et prendre
en charge une partie des loyers dans des
cas très précis donc cette phase a été
ouverte effectivement le 15 avril et va
se poursuivre mais la première est
encore ouverte
il faut vraiment j'encourage vraiment
nos petits commerçants nos tpe et les
wasaï postuler au maximum
il y avait plusieurs actions de la
région
tout d'abord nous avons débloqué un
fonds d'équipement de nos médecins
libéraux infirmières libérales sages
femmes libérales et également les
pharmaciens 110 millions d'euros pour
s'équiper par exemple un médecin qui
veut faire de la télé médecine qui a
besoin d'acheter un ordinateur ou webcam
d du matériel stérile d'un évidemment et
caetera et donc on l'a décidé d'ouvrir
aux pharmacies on voit beaucoup dans nos
pharmacies des techs place la région que
les rembourser sur facture et il ya
aussi une énorme opération de
distribution de masques par la région on
a été plutôt réactif au tout début de
cette crise pour commander massivement
des masques via nos relations franco
chinoises notamment on en a commandé 30
millions d'euros il y en a plus de 10
millions d'euros qui ont eu 10 millions
pas donc qui ont été distribués alors en
priorité aux personnels soignants à
thiers à peu près à la rs aux hôpitaux
un deuxième tiers au maire et au
département à hauteur de 20 % de leur
population notamment pour les ehpad
également tout le personnel qui les
policiers municipaux par exemple ils
sont en contact avec la population les
personnes qui ramassent des ordures etc
les résidences qui accueille les
personnes handicapées et là maintenant
on le décline également vers l'activité
économique on va commencer très
prochainement peut-être demain une
opération pour équiper les commerçants
qui sont restés ouverts des très petites
entreprises
on a fait la semaine des as toutes les
pharmacies parce qu'il ya des besoins et
d'un qui ne sont pas satisfaits
pour les lycées en tout cas ce qui est
prévu de la part la région c'est
d'équipé évidemment tous nos agents en
masque déjà dans un premier temps
sachant que l'éducation nationale doit
se charger d'équiper les professeurs et
les élèves
donc on attend vraiment avec impatience
que va annoncer le premier ministre en
tout cas notre côté nous serons prêts
qui paie évidemment nos agents en masque
par ailleurs vous savez que il en
septembre dernier la région a fait une à
l'équipement à proposer un équipement au
lycée en matériel informatique
la moitié des lycées à peu près ont
choisi cette option du numérique et donc
c'est vrai que ça nous permet d'avoir
une reprise peut-être vraiment le
transitoire et l graduée puisque il ya
une possibilité encore une fois de le
faire à distance
je vous propose à présent de prendre la
direction de saint malo pour y retrouver
le skipper louis burton bonjour bonjour
alors on le rappelle vous êtes
originaire de rambouillet mais vous avez
choisi de passer ce confinement en
famille en bretagne alors ma première
question comment ça se passe bah ça se
passe bien j'ai quitté rambouillet il ya
quelques années déjà et en effet on est
installé à saint malo on a la chance
d'avoir une maison un peu dans la
campagne donc c'est plutôt agréable pour
les enfants ils peuvent aller courir et
donc on est un peu privilégiés par
rapport à ça est-ce que vous avez un
planning type chaque jour oui alors en
fait depuis trois semaines on a réouvert
l'entreprise donc on essaye de ne pas
être plus de deux personnes à la fois
dans l'atelier de préparation de bureau
vallée du bateau chacun met des masques
et puis on fait une rotation toutes les
semaines voilà donc moi je vais au
bureau maintenant tous les jours et puis
à la maison on fait des courses une fois
par semaine quand y avait école mais les
petits bretons la sai et des slovaques
hausse mais quand il y avait école on
faisait l'école le matin et puis l'après
midi plutôt ludique est libre et voilà
et on fait beaucoup beaucoup à manger on
fait beaucoup de repas
oui comme tous les français j'ai envie
de dire voilà les français qui se sont
découvert une passion pour la cuisine
pendant ce confinement
donc c'est votre cas aussi alors vous
parlez de réouverture de votre
entreprise justement vous devez
participer à la prochaine édition du
vendée globe
vous savez si c'est alors c'est en
novembre prochain donc il ya encore
quelques mois vous savez si s'est
maintenu alors oui on travaille beaucoup
en fait aux avec le
l'organisateur de la course donc depuis
les dernières annonces du président de
la république que l'organisateur donc la
région vendée a communiqué la semaine
dernière pour dire que sauf mention
sanitaire contraire le vendée globe
serait maintenu il y aura un village
parce que c'est une grande fête
populaire le vendée globe et et donc il
y aura bien un village alors ce sera
peut-être un village avec des mesures
sanitaires adaptés en fonction de moi on
est dans la pandémie mais la course sera
bien lieu donc tous les projets on est
une trentaine de bateaux normalement sa
ligne à cette course va essayer de
s'organiser pour être prêt à aller
naviguer dès qu'on aura à nouveau
l'autorisation du coup c'est par rapport
à cette situation vous avez pris un
petit peu de retard j'imagine pour cette
préparation retard que vous allez sans
doute rattrapé
oui en fait c'est sûr content de là on
devait mettre normalement bureau vallée
à l'eau on va avoir peut-être par
rapport à notre planning un mois de
retard on espère pouvoir mettre à l'eau
en fête le 15 mai au lieu du 15 avril
c'est sûr que du coup l'été va être va
pas être trop reposant on va pas pouvoir
trop partir en vacances je pense et on
devrait réussir à rattraper le temps
perdu en mettant à profit les mois d'été
où on va essayer de maintenir une
activité à 100% alors que c'est plutôt
une période habituellement ou où
l'équipe part en part plongé
alternativement donc voilà je pense que
si on reste dans ce dans ce time in las
de déconfinement on devrait être capable
de s'aligner au départ du vendée globe
dans de bonnes conditions
alors pour vous qu'est-ce qui est le
plus compliqué dans ce confinement le
manque de la mer j'imagine alors c'est
sûr que d'un point de vue personnel le
fait de ne pas pouvoir aller en mer
autant qu'on veut
bon c'était compliqué parce que c'est
c'est vrai que l'on a la chance de vivre
de notre passion et puis on est on est
là pour ça on adore ça moi j'adore ça
donc c'est un peu compliqué après non ce
qui est ce qui a été le plus difficile à
gérer mais je pense comme tous les tous
les chefs d'entreprise et tous les
français c'est de ne pas vraiment savoir
de quoi le lendemain va être fait de
quelle manière on va pouvoir retrouver
une vie à peu près normale
voilà c'est sûr que cette cette phase on
n'est pas habitué à ça ou en fait même
les mêmes nos dirigeants etc ne savent
pas exactement comment les choses vont
se passer
le vrai du faux style effect news les
bonnes news etc
donc voilà il ya tout un travail
intellectuel et psychologique qu'il faut
arriver à faire
justement vous parlez de psychologie
alors vous vous avez l'habitude
évidemment d'être d'être confinés dans
un espace réduit est ce que les skippers
finalement sont mieux armés pour pour
vivre ce confinement
non je pense qu'on a on a quelques on a
quelques habitudes qui font que on se
sent peut-être moins empressées que que
des personnes qui n'ont jamais connu ça
personnellement ça se passe bien je
pense que pour pas mal de skippers du
vendée globe c'est une période qui se
passe bien parce que c'est vrai que on a
l'habitude sur un tour du monde de
partir pendant trois mois tout seul des
dents dans des surfaces de vie qui sont
très restreintes
donc on est on est parmi les mieux armés
en effet pour traverser cette période
est ce que vous pourriez partage est
justement de trois conseils pour les
téléspectateurs de tv 78 pour mieux
vivre ce confinement
bon je pense que c'est un peu commencé
un peu comme en vélo quand on attaque
une cote difficile il faut plutôt
regarder devant sa roue et par regarder
tant de la montagne
il faut avancer au jour le jour il faut
garder dans un coin de sa tête a laissé
à terre où les choses qu'on avait prévu
de faire du confinement actuelle partir
en vacances voyages etc et et garder ça
dans un coin de sa tête quand même un
peu un rêve comme quelque chose qu'on
souhaite retrouver
et puis avancer avancer pas à pas pour
pas que pour pas que la pente paraître
paraît trop difficile je pense qu'il
faut ensuite beaucoup lire comme
beaucoup s'informer continuer à débattre
avec ses proches
et puis essayer de positiver en
réfléchissant aux conséquences positives
corps à ce confinement sur notre avenir
immédiat et notre avenir à plus ou moins
long terme merci louis burton en tout
cas pour ses conseils et bon courage
pour la suite et pour finir un mot de
culture en raison de la crise sanitaire
le château de rambouillet vient
d'annoncer le report du spectacle secret
défense en juin 2021
ce spectacle immersif avec plus de 600
bénévoles proposera de faire revivre une
rencontre entre le général de gaulle est
le président eisenhower
il devait initialement se jouer en juin
prochain mais en attendant que le
château réouvre ses portes
et bien vous pouvez continuer de le
visiter mais de manière virtuelle le
domaine participent au dispositif
culture chez nous et vous propose sur
son site internet et sa page facebook de
partir à sa découverte au programme des
jeux et contenus inédits et des
coloriages pour les enfants voilà c'est
la fin de cette édition spéciale merci
de l'avoir suivi et restez chez vous et
prenez bien soin de vous
[Musique]